لست راضيا ولكنني دائما اعرف انني الوحيد
الذي اريد المزيد حصلت على اربع جوائز
واريد الجائزه الخامسه انوي الحصول على
مجموعه الحذاء الذهبي كامله وهذه الجوائز
اضافيه لريال مدريد كاكبر نادي في العالم
ويجب ان يربح الالقاب في كل عام تابع
رونالدو تقديم عروض مذهله مع ريال مدريد
ومهاراته تتطور في شكل متواصل وقد تطور
ليصبح لاعبا اساسيا في الفريق بفضل مواسم
رائعه واصل رونالدو الفوز باربع جوائز كره
ذهبيه اخرى ليصل الى رقم قياسيا بخمس
جوائز وهو رقم حققه مره واحده فقط قبله
خصمه اللدود ومنافسه في الدوري الاسباني
ليونيل ميسي
الفائز هو كريستيانو رونالدو
[تصفيق]
انه احد افضل اللاعبين على مر الزمان ولا
احد يستطيع قول غير ذلك انه من افضل
اللاعبين على مر العصور بكل بساطه
يقولون انه افضل لاعب في العالم ويتناقشون
في شان بيليه مارادونا ولابد من وجودهما
في المعادله لانهما كان لاعبين مذهلين لكن
اعتقد ان الجدير بالقول ان بيليه لم
ينافسه لاعبون معاصرون وكذلك
في ظل غياب منافسين يتحدونهما اما رونالدو
فينافسه ميسي وميسي ينافسه رونالدو وقد
ساعد ذلك كليهما
وكان سجالا سنويا لاعوام متلاحقه عندما
يحين موعد جائزه الكره الذهبيه رونالدو ام
ميسي وكل محبا لكره القدم في العالم له
راي في ذلك وقد يتغير ذلك الراي لان
الاداء والنجاح متبادلان بينهما لكن
الحقيقه ان كل منهما احرز خمس جوائز كره
ذهبيه لم يفترق مطلقا حين يتقدم احدهما
يتمكن الاخر من مطاردته وتقليص الفارق
ويبدو مناسبا حصول كل منهما على خمس منها
على الرغم من ان رونالدو معروف بلاعبه
لفريق ريال مدريد انتشرت شائعه من جديد
بانه يتطلع الى الانتقال الى نادي اخر لا
احد يدري
الله وحده يعلم لا اعلم ما يخبئه المستقبل
لكنني سعيد جدا مع ريال مدريد لا احد يدري
مع انتهاء عقده عام 2018 كانت مساله وقت
فحسب قبل ان يعرف الجمهور مكان مخبا
للفائز بجائزه الكره الذهبيه خمس مرات